do washed up celebs like deborah messing
regret giving sleepy joe their blessing
yes she was the star of will and grace
but voting for biden left her with egg
on her face
suddenly i'm hungry
cena reports that following the supreme
court's overruling of roe v wade debra
messing and a bunch of other liberal
celebs and activists recently joined a
call with white house staff who took uh
time off updating their resumes
but according to people on the call
messing was a mask quote
she said she'd gotten joe biden elected
and wanted to know why she was being
asked to do anything at all yelling that
there didn't seem even seem a point to
voting others wondered why the call was
happening end quote like to add that but
she wasn't the only one confused
including joe himself who kept trying to
answer his stapler
worse after that call participants were
then given biden speech clips to share
on tick-tock
that's the app that chyna uses to spy on
idiots so it makes sense
i'd say that's as organic as a twinkie
but then brian stelter would try to eat
it
oh my gosh so yeah the creeps that
elected joe are now losing confidence in
him as cnn admits some of the loudest
members of his party are wondering if
he's if he's even equipped to deal with
everything happening around him
challenges like the war in ukraine crime
inflation and of course the worst thing
climbing stairs
anyway i wonder what joe has to say
about all this
no no no look look
deborah messing i don't need her
will and grace she wasn't even the best
person on that show
should have been called will and that
other gay guy
i can say that right
and they voted for me
i mean
i'm fun
and they're fun doesn't that what gay
means happy fun look at their parades
they're having a blast
sometimes when i talk too long i whisper
and then nobody remembers what i said
before the whisper
matt
deborah messing believes that she got
joe biden elected when everybody knows
it was alyssa milano right she's the
boss well i know that when they're
having these troubles they bring
celebrities to the rescue yeah but
is anyone surprised that the person who
campaigned from their basement couldn't
fill five hula hoops with people
is now having a problem uh running the
largest country in the world i mean it's
not surprising to me i forgot about the
hula hoops
those were the good old the good old
days yeah why do you think they're
panicking now
well i mean they see a
cataclysmic
loss in 22
and you know they let's get one applause
uh
and the other joe biden
maybe he'll get out of here you know
this me out i mean if you think about
how this lines up is you know they're
starting to say
can he do it should he run in 24 it's a
disaster you know people are jumping off
yes
ss biden and so then the lawson 22 is
going to confirm that they need to dump
him over the side yeah tyrus do you look
too deborah messing for your political
guidance
get the bleep button right no
um
i told you this was going to happen yes
i've been told you this is going to be
you just said it like six months ago
biden was not the end goal
so they're their little it's not their
plans it's not that they've and
they've embodied and excited the wrong
part of our society they've spit in the
face of our police they've spit in
education
all because it's their part of their
progressive woke agenda and biden was a
moderate but they needed him bernie
couldn't do it by himself so he's in
they're going to blame everything on him
and now they'll get the celebrities that
come forward to say he's wrong and then
eventually within the next two months
they'll be talking about his capacity to
understand and stuff and then we'll have
you know a christmas present for
everybody get the bongos out because
it'll be kamala it's going to be all
better
i'm telling hey boo whatever watch bet
yes
by the way bongos make her like totally
phenomenal yeah you put bongos behind
what she says everything's amazing i'm
yeah i would invest in bongos right now
yes
and just get him out at home when she
comes on and
it's incredible you won't be as sad as
you thought i i it is like it's like
when you play uh dark side of the moon
while you're watching with a wizard of
oz
right cat
yeah i've done that
that's true uh what do you make of this
do you think this is just normal
no
it's not which again i think all of
these democrats that are talking about
what biden should be doing their
expectations are way too high
uh they shouldn't be uh the stuff
they're saying is you know he needs to
work harder and strike the right tone
it's not enough for him to just give one
speech and then disappear but it's as if
they forget this is the guy that we all
saw carrying around a note card that
says you take your seat yes
the expectations are it's like if you're
dating a guy who's awful and he cheats
on you all the time and he hates you and
you're like oh what he should do is give
me my dream proposal like probably but
he's probably not going to they need to
realize that this is a lost cause and
just move on my dream proposal
you know sandra they're describing him
as rudderless
aimless and hopeless
sounds like geraldo on his yacht
if you laughed at that that's very mean
um
what do you think so that was a
democratic lawmaker yeah on cnn right um
so you're hearing this just about
everywhere you asked matt why are they
so fed up you were referencing the
celebrities who pushed for this
presidency and the answer is in every
single data point every single poll i
know you love when i bring my notes but
i am your straight news anchor on the
show gallop 23 of the american people a
mere 23 percent have confidence in the
institution of the presidency today
record low monmouth university just 10
percent believe that this country is
heading in the right direction right now
the president's approval rating sinking
to an all-time low 36
you've got the washington post pushing
for this president to usher in a
different vibe do something yeah i mean
they're fed up my only concern though is
that that's grabbing headlines for
democrats and for this administration
because they care about the celebrities
what they're not caring enough about is
the average american who's suffering
through this inflation lack of baby
formula sky high inflation gas prices
the very people this administration says
that they are setting out to help are
the ones who are hurting the most right
now i will i have to move on but i will
say there is a big piece of fake news
here debra messing is not a celebrity
come on we're lowering the bar
blowing the bar on celebrities
[Laughter]
every bar for me has to be lowered
up next
a lawmaker gave twerking a shot
and won the vote of sir mix-a-lot
favorite story
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else